this is the proposal that uh you're
investigating it's known as project
diffuse um and uh it's essentially a
proposal to DARPA the Defense Agency uh
to collect and manipulate bat viruses
ostensibly for the purpose of predicting
what kind of viruses might jump from
bats to humans and cause future
pandemics uh and you summarize one of
their proposals this way that the
scientists sought to insert fur and
cleavage sites at the S1 S2 Junction of
the spike
protein to assemble synthetic uh viruses
in six segments to identify Corona
viruses up to 25% different from SARS
and to select for receptor binding
domains Adept at infecting human
receptors and then you go with these
bullet points and you list kind of one
by one the character istics that SARS
COV 2 the ways in which it matches the
viruses that are described in this
proposal so SARS COV 2 has a furin
cleavage site which we has been
discussed at length and we can talk
about a little bit more later uh sarov 2
can be divided into six contiguous
genomic Pieces by the restriction
enzymes uh bsal and
bmbl um and orders for one of those
enzymes BML can be found in the
documents and the receptor binding
domain appeared finally tuned for human
ace2 receptor uh and then the genome has
the genetic differences from
SARS
um so here's where I want to bring in
Alex to help explain the significance of
their plans to assemble the viruses
specifically in those six segments using
some very specific enzymes could you
explain that for us uh a little bit more
deeply Alex absolutely yeah and one kind
of interesting backstory is that the
defuse Grant was proposed to the DARPA
preempt call in 2018 and I had submitted
or helped write in a
success as well so this call is very
intimately familiar to me and um in that
context what was distinct about diffuse
was their search for this Motif that had
never been seen in the SARS Corona virus
before the fear leage site and their
proposal to insert this thing that had
never been seen before in a SARS Corona
virus and so the proposal to insert a
fing cleavage site instantly puts them
down a particular laboratory path so how
do you insert a f and cleavage site into
a SARS Corona virus the SARS coronav
virus has this RNA genome which you can
think of this really flimsy film of a
genetic strand of RNA and it breaks very
easily it's very hard to insert motifs
inside of an RNA genome so if you you
want to insert if you're in cleavage
site you have to build this much
sturdier DNA copy of the virus and in
order to build this sturdy DNA copy of
the virus you have to build it one block
at a time we looked into the preco well
I guess not not we but Valentine brell
and Tony van dongan had looked these are
bioengineers Valentine in University of
rburg and Tony at Duke
University um they're bioengineers they
build these DNA blocks um from scratch
so they looked into the methods for how
people did this in Corona viruses pre-co
and found that one of the most common
methods for building these fulllength
DNA clones of a virus was to order these
blocks and nip them at the end with
these restriction sites that allow you
to attach them one at a time until
eventually you have that fulllength DNA
clone and one of the diffus pis really
popularized this this technique Ralph
baric wrote a paper on efficient reverse
genetics systems well that's a lot of
words it just means reverse genetics is
you have this DNA clone that you're
tinkering with to make these different
RNA viruses and in the process
experimenting with the role between
these genes and the and the
manipulations of these genes like if
you're in cleavage site on the function
of the virus um so that was kind of the
context we looked into this diffuse
proposal and asked okay if they're
inserting a fear and cleavage site they
need a full length the and clone if
you're building a full length theed
clone they're probably using
methodologies like those that Ralph
baric popularized is there any evidence
for this in the SARS 2 genome we studied
a met we ran a meta analysis of all
these infectious clones and RSE genetic
systems made before covid and found that
they all had this characteristic manner
of manipulation the researchers would
look at the Genome of the virus on the
computer screen look at where these
cutting sites are and they move them
around a little bit to make it easier to
assemble these blocks and they would
move these cutting sites around with
these mutations called Silent mutations
that change the genetic sequence without
changing the resulting virus so
researchers before covid would make
these full length DNA clones by using
silent mutations to move these cutting
sites that form these little notches
that you can use to attach chunks of DNA
together to build that full length clone
we looked into that and found that SARS
2 had this very unusual pattern of
evenly spaced cutting sites um that was
consistent with how people built reverse
genetic systems before covid and that
when you look closer at these cutting
sites yeah this is the figure here those
cutting sites bsnb one and bsa1
typically are randomly spaced throughout
the genome when you have randomly spaced
things they don't often come with
fragments of this similar size but when
you look at this visually Valentine and
Tony had just screamed at them this is
unusual and they have much they have a
lot of experience seeing what you see in
the the other soars K2 is the top row
here all the other viruses um you know
from vanal 20 247 to Stars
One their bsm1 and bsa1 sites are
randomly scattered and that's what you
typically see when you upload a genome
into this software that helps you see
the cutting sites Valentine and Tony
uploaded Stars 2 saw this unusual
pattern and thought wow this is like an
Ikea virus you know this is something
you could just order right from scratch
and get this allen wrench of bsnb one
and the screwdriver of bsa1 and Stitch
it together so the question then was
what are the odds of this occurring in
nature and that's where I came in as a
mathematical biologist to study the
evolution of Corona viruses and try to
get an estimate on the odds of this
appearing in nature given that it is so
consistent with a reverse genetic system
we found those odds were really low so
when you the way we estimated it was
looking at this longest fragment length
so this top figure here the y axis is
the length of the longest fragment from
cutting up a virus with any one or any
pair of these enzymes and then the
x-axis is a number of fragments when
Ralph baric wrote his paper on efficient
reverse genetic systems he proposed that
red box as this idealized range for an
efficient reverse genetic system
somewhere between five to eight
fragments and ideally less than 8,000
base pairs long for the longest fragment
because when you order these chunks of
DNA online um 8,000 base pairs is a
common cut off now that said the longer
the fragment is the more the more likely
it is to either contain a toxic element
that prevents your ability to replicate
it and clone it and make a lot of it um
and it also reduces the odds of faithful
assembly when you have a really long
Wiggly piece of DNA it may not attach as
Faithfully or at high of rate um as
shorter fragments so there's a
preference to have smaller fragments in
general and that's what really was the
lurking lab protocol constraints that
led to this pattern of unusually even
spacing in these restriction sites so we
looked at the we Quantified the odds of
seeing something as or more extrem as
too just in the pattern the spacing of
these sites and that was about a 1 in4
1400 event um so one out of 14,000 this
is actually the most extreme case of a
Corona virus that we've seen for these
enzymes that can be used for the
Assembly of these reverse genetic
systems then we look further at the
silent mutations that's where we found
hot spots like glowing genetic dust
right on these specific sites and
wherever they were moved around they
were moved around exclusively with the
mutations bioengineers used
and that was our most significant
finding and so this is what you know the
title of your paper is uh
endonuclear print uh indicates a
synthetic origin of sarov 2 so the
fingerprint that you're referring to
there is essentially the fact that there
are let me pull up that figure one more
time these rather
evenly uh space like somewhat regularly
L length uh segments as opposed to in a
naturally occurring virus you would get
uh much you'd get much more variation in
the length you'd get some really short
ones and some really long ones um and so
it's just mathematically unusual for
that or you know maybe even
mathematically impossible or highly
improbable that that would occur in
nature I want to give credit to DARPA
they invented the internet and they
rejected diffuse so this a diffuse
proposal of interest you know diffuse
proposal reveals the attentions of these
researchers who previously had conducted
a lot of gain of function research of
concern they would find these bat Corona
viruses lurking in nature and they would
swap around these parts of the that
coron virus making these chimeras to
then ask oh which Chimera is the most
infectious in people and that question
is modifying things found in nature to
improve their transmissibility and the
intention their search was for something
more transmissible so you would expect
this research program to result in
something more transmissible because
that's what what they were trying to
make and the fear and cleavage site
specifically was well known before covid
that fear and cleavage sites are found
in other viruses and when they're found
in other viruses they're kind of this
master key that allow the virus to
unlock all sorts of different host cells
and enter into bat cells and human cells
and dogs and whatever um so the fear and
cleavage site was this master key why
would you give that to a SARS Corona
virus thus anticipated to improve the
transmissibility of this virus possibly
improve the VAR as well if the virus is
able to infect more tissues within the
human body so that the insertion of the
fear and cleavage site was the gain of
function research of concern and that's
just to just to be really uh clear for
our listeners who may not have been
following every detail of this the the
fear and cleavage site the reason that
there's so much attention on it is
because a um it is this SARS COV 2 is
the only virus in its category of these
SARS likee Corona viruses that has it
and B that makes it particular hum uh
particularly susceptible to it it's it
it eases the entry into human cells is
that more or less the reason why the
fear and cleavage site was like the the
first kind of red flag for people who
thought that this might have originated
in a lab that's exactly right a fearing
cleavage site had never been observed
before in aar's Corona virus and we when
we build the evolutionary tree of aar's
coron virus before covid we had a
thousand years of branches in this tree
and there wasn't a single indication
that a SARS Corona virus existed
anywhere in that tree yet they were very
prominent in the minds of urologists and
this is where I can speak as you know
someone who is in that DARPA preempt
community of accepted grants that we all
knew that the biggest Crux for these
jump capable quasi species the biggest
Crux for host switching is binding onto
the receptors of a new host because new
hosts have very different funky recept
ctors in their cells so how can a virus
latch onto that and enter into the cell
the fear and cleide assists with that
process and it was known to assist with
that process so virologists everywhere
were looking for these things because
they really wanted to find them if you
found a f and cleavage site and for
instance an influenza virus that passed
through a chicken farm which they did
once and one chicken farm out of all the
chicken farms that had been infected
with this that was documented and it was
explosive news because virologists
understood the context so if you're in
cev s it was a motif this master key
that biologists knew about but nature
didn't or nature knew about it would
stumble upon it randomly but had not
stumbled upon it in the 10,000 years of
SARS coronavirus Evolution that we've
seen yet then we find a SARS Corona
virus with this master key in Wuhan
exactly where researchers proposed to
give it to asars coronav virus so that's
the fear and cleavage site that's the
gain of function research of concern
component and our work was focused more
on the laboratory
protocols that they had said they want
wanted to find all these Wildlife Corona
viruses so we usually go out you catch a
bat you sample its poop or its mouth or
whatever and then you send that into a
lab and you sequence it when you
sequence it you get this long genetic
code 30,000 base pairs on a computer now
how can you go from that genetic code
then saying ah this virus is more likely
to infect people or less likely to
infect people for that we use all these
laboratory techniques to construct parts
of the virus or entire viruses and our
work was focused on that both the
rescuing of virus from a genetic
sequence using these reverse genetic
systems or infectious clones and that
that's a really remarkable thing to
think about is that most viruses go from
a virus to cell to a virus to cell to
virus to cell and you can trace that
back in time infinite indefinitely to
the origins of the virus but infectious
clones they go from a virus to a cell to
a poop sample in a bat to a genome on a
computer screen and then from that
genome on a computer screen we order
these blocks and Stitch them together
and then we make from that DNA clone
this RNA we electrocute a cell to form
these holes in it an electr paraded cell
and shove that RNA inside the cell it
starts making a virus it's this sort of
Immaculate Conception of modern
biotechnology and that was the most
common way of rescuing Corona viruses
from these Wildlife samples um where you
could have the genome but you may not
have cultured the virus the virus may
have died while it was being transported
to a lab but you can still get the
genome you can still get the virus you
can still study it and that methodology
was also Inus but it was a bit more
Technical and subtle to find these
fingerprints in the genome but that's
what we found hey thanks for watching
that clip from our new show just asking
questions you can watch another clip
here or the full episode here new
episodes drop every week so subscribe to
reent TV's YouTube channel to get
notified when that happens or to the
just asking questions podcast on Apple
Spotify or any other podcatcher see you
next week